do you have a top five uh
best rappers of all time in your opinion
well okay yeah um in order from like um
five to one five to one the one being
the best yeah okay five i would have to
say xxx centasyon he was a good friend
of mine uh-huh um
for little peep um i i didn't know him
but his his music was amazing
uh three juice world rest in peace the
m2 we all came kind of up from the sound
clutter
wow all three guys his name have passed
it's sad right uh three uh uh so one two
two rounded two two i would say king von
rest in peace again um
and one who actually was a good friend
of mine mac miller in [ __ ]
and it's all five what did they all die
of
uh drug overdoses and gunshots yeah
gunshots and mack was the drug overdose
but as a story about mac was um
i started listening to mac in 2009 when
i was like 12 or something you know
and um and i fell in love with his music
and
i fell in love with how every album
it was a different mac it was a it like
his whole discography from the beginning
to the end is and he's just watching the
evolution was amazing so he became my
favorite artist throughout the years of
me
dropping out of high school bumping into
music and then my music brought us
together later in life which blew my
mind because that was my idol you know
what i mean and then he invited me to
actually what would be his last show at
the hotel cafe in uh
in in downtown
and um i got to see him perform 100
people it was like you had to win like a
radio giveaway to go there very intimate
i met his family i met jason sedegas
when he was with olivia wilde back there
john mayer wow and uh and mack was like
yo uh next week let's uh
or like next month let's uh uh come over
and let's jam out and i was like wow i'm
gonna make a song with my idol that's
crazy you know so i left i said it was a
good show and then i was born september
6th uh he died september 7th
and so we never got to do that and then
after that after mack miller passed that
would that hurt me the most that
wouldn't hurt me yeah and you decided
that you were going to not make music
yo if if uh if my producer is here he'd
make fun of that uh comment right now so
much he says why do you retire every
month like you know what i mean i
i i i do it as a joke you know what i
mean but at the at the time with the mac
thing when i was crying on live i
probably did feel like i wanted to
retire but now i just do it as a [ __ ]
joke like i'm like oh i retired until i
come back you know
right i just think like whenever
somebody loses a loved one you know it
it's it's sad
you should grieve
i i urge people to grieve selfishly
you know and then get it get over it and
move on and and
let your motivation be
to honor
the the memory of your loved one
by
being happy and healthy
like that like your loved one would want
you to be yeah if i were to ask you what
do you think mac miller would want for
you he would be like [ __ ] dude get
out there and make me his last words
to me were be safe
all right and he mac would want you to
make music if mac heard that you were
gonna not make music because he died
that that's not that's not honoring i
think yeah i think it was just because
it was the day after my birthday and it
was just in the moment you know but i'm
i'm not retired at all you know my my
next album is on my birthday september
6th
um
and it's called diego yeah that's when
it's dropping yeah september 6th
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and
sky jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]
you